the entertainment world is mourning the
loss of Emmy winning actress Valerie
Harper she was 80 years old and lost a
long and public battle with a rare form
of brain cancer
Valerie Harper launched to stardom in
her role as Rhoda on the beloved 76 Comm
The Mary Tyler Moore Show Jim Axelrod
takes a look at her life and her career
look if I felt that way I'd never go to
a Paul Newman movie maybe the highest
praise for Valerie Harper's skill on
screen is that for many of her fans she
wasn't Valerie at all she was Rhoda I
don't know why I'm putting this in my
mouth
I should just apply it directly to my
hips Mary's best friend on The Mary
Tyler Moore Show the spunky lovable
sidekick Rhoda was funny because she was
a scuffle ER and she was you know just
in life trying to feeling like a loser
but somehow winning Harper who started
on Broadway in the 50s and did movies
like Lil Abner was so successful on The
Mary Tyler Moore Show starting in 1970
that she got her own spin-off sitcom
four years later I really must love you
I feel so sorry for you but her most
challenging role was also her most
inspiring the courageous way Valerie
Harper handled cancer first diagnosed 10
years ago with lung cancer she announced
four years later it had spread to her
brain told she had months left she
battled six more years instead don't go
to the funeral before the day of the
funeral
providing so many moving lessons in her
last chapter to go along with all those
laughs she'd given us in the years
before don't smear my makeup for CBS
this morning Saturday this is Jim
Axelrod in New York what a wonderful
legacy yeah and what a fighter yeah what
a fighter loved her so much